what if you had purchased Apple stock
before the launch of the iPhone what if
you had bought Amazon before it was the
only place people shopped at hindsight
financial you don't have to wonder how
rich you could have been because we'll
show you the frustrating detail our
advisors will walk you through every
single opportunity you missed we even
show you luxury items you could have
acquired if you only invest it before
things took off the trappings of wealth
and distinction that could have been
yours if you just listened to your
co-workers tip I'm telling you man
I don't think so how do you have this
hindsight is not just 20/20 it's also
incredibly frustrated let us show you
how many years earlier you could have
retired how little you - Oh in college
loans and meet the spouse you could have
traded up - oh the life you would have
had it's almost too much in what's our
fee the very low commission of just 10%
of every dollar you would have earned
had you invested it's a small price to
pay to see the car you would be driving
to the mansion you'd have built on the
island you could have owned now you're
probably wondering will we then help you
learn from your mistakes and make
investments today that will bring you
wealth tomorrow no you don't do that but
you will get these hats hindsight
financial coulda should
by the service
you